e amici bellissimi oggi c'è un video
particolare sul gioco ancora mai fatto
che deve essere imposto loro è una roba
nuova oggi solo volti anonimi cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che quello due botti una
persona non si vede chi ha votato chi
quindi vedrete una vittoria pazzesca
perché adatta benissimo ragazzi buona
visione
[Musica]
ragazzi non mi ricordato e mutarli su di
esse sarebbe stato ma il problema visto
che sono impostore è da un po che non
gioco e da una settimana quindi ho perso
un attimo verve però sapete che faccio
mesto qua e aspetto che arrivi marci
così io vado via non meno male che non
l'ho ucciso o meno male che non l'ho
ucciso perché mi è venuto in mente di e
normo lo ammazzo così poi entrò nel
ranch subito però che c'è anche noi a
mamma mia ma meno male o è morto è morto
nel eletti non l'ho assegnato io non ho
capito con impianti a questi forti
minuto 30 sono anonimi e così è
veramente chi non ha mai a praga
io ho votato stai fa caldo poi dici che
sono io quello che ti accusa allora
dobbiamo muoverci ragazzi sono veramente
troppe poche tasche ma troppe troppo
poche ce ne sono
non ci sono tasche mannaia la morte
quindi il problema è questo dobbiamo
muoverci allora ed i ragazzi sarebbe
charlie ed è di sarebbe charlie quindi è
importante questo schiacciarli non siamo
sinergici non sono sinergo dei players
se le top players cosa simile forte ciao
aumentato ventato andiamo a vedere se
c'è qualcuno no vabbè lasciamo libera
allora allora ho trovato vessicchio e
morto anche ma di comunque tra dove il
secchio morto davanti all'ingresso di
electrical io avevo appena fatto la cosa
di ossigeno in ad mi stavo scendendo all
ora per mano una missione e non ho visto
nessuno a passare di lì c'è odio stefan
tratto ma mi sembra che arrivasse
dall'altro non voglio dire una cavolata
io sono entrato ad admin sia arrivati
dall'alto ok un ed è votare per forza
lanciata in elettrica lei non ci sono
mai entrata sono passato davanti
elettrica si ma il corpo infatti ora
davanti elettrica nder ad esempio ok era
fuori secondo me la butto lì potrebbero
essere adesso che mb a fare le provette
però dobbiamo fare dobbiamo votare
perché sennò perdiamo che fanno io vedo
suddetti che prima era vicina altro
corpo perché la rai non ci posso credere
non ci posso credere
ragazzi non c'entrava niente non
c'entrava niente
ho votato che noia perché queste noi
accusa gli altri sempre di miglietta
facciamo ora abbiamo vinto l'adesione
abbiamo vinto convinto che basta che
ammazza il primo che vedo parla proprio
killer secca e vinta
la fossa e va bene a nessuno io voglio
sapere chi è il terzo cavallo che noi
avevano votato napoli grazie bere birra
grazie del video
[Musica]
mai vista una partita dei scende sono
anche il rosso quando sono rosso in
genere faccio un miliardo di chili sono
altri momenti avrebbe molto senso trova
niente il mio colore raga questo qua in
casa ci penso perché quando sono rosso
faccio disastri juve sistema bensì che
il buon vessicchio quest'anno anche
questa è una tasca che non fake ha mai
nessuno ragazze c'è qualcuno che fa con
le tasche perché effettivamente secondo
me non sto applicando cioè fei chi le
tasche un po più evidenti quindi non è
per sicuro andrà il presente non è fare
nomi che elettrica ranieri
sto dicendo quando c'è stata allora io
stavo camminando lo vedevo una c'è può
però mi è comparso il tasto report ed
evidentemente sera in cadavere di staff
dov'è morto stesso che non avevo visto
posso parlare
puoi parlare parla io mi fido e nate ma
l'ho fatto solo perché no no no no risk
with era che ci sta deve 4 e rai a vuoto
per my style hutton ora ci ributtiamo
stesso era morto facciamo notare la
patente così successo cioè per lui
potrebbe essere morto due volte
rimbombano lasciare gip il tar è un
impostore non è bianco kickback vado a
ha votato oggi in val polista è una cosa
sto vedendo serve continua a tornare in
vita ma basta ma cos'è abbiamo è
successo di tutto ciò è per niente nate
era eccitato per giustamente mi che se
fossi stato in atto sarei andato io a
cagliari da step che vedete quindi
capisco tutto quello che sta succedendo
solidarietà annate gli schede al canale
di nat però il discorso è che il surf
continua a tornare in vita quindi è un
po strano
adesso tirol emergency per vedere se
stessa è tornato in vita theo emergenti
sono per questo motivo la mia vita per
votarlo perché è tornato mythos terre
perfetta realizzati sono morto sono
morto scusate ai mantovani cavalli
come morto mamma ma fate le tasche per
sé non può essere lei sta applicando
troppo bene vessicchio potrebbe essere
vestiti lo vedo camminare troppo a caso
a meno che non sia capendo che sono
morte sotto marci ma ci sono ragazzi aia
volanti sono nonno torna in vita
dobbiamo trovare gli impostori e stato
ogni spicchio persona che è stato rimane
vero io non mi aspettavo mai che non
prendo l'ho preso perchè ero davanti a
tutti come hanno fatto meno danni del
secchio 6 orbo 6 orbo sarai direttore
d'orchestra ma ora stessi che ha
cambiato colore guardalo davanti alla
gente guarda subito ho capito subito che
faceva perché non lo votate mai stefano
baldi
io avrei votato stefano essendo mi
seguite mai questa è stata una puntata
di oggi di amgas my friends studiano ha
proseguito che tra due giorni come
sempre ormai ne faccio uscire con ogni
due giorni massimo mentre ragazzi
servite più starci per i commenti ma
lasciate anche mi piace perché sapete
che noi ci nutriamo lasciateli come
sempre ci rivediamo ad un prossimo video
ragazzi
[Musica]